we're back and we're in the middle of
trying to learn from the way that HIV
infects a human cell to understand how
we might better introduce health
innovations into complex human systems
so that we can have implementation and
permanence of the change and then spread
or scale-up of that change we've already
gone through a couple of steps of the
virus life cycle and then pulled out
some lessons that we can learn that
might apply we think do apply to the
introduction of innovations into human
systems so now we're going to go on to a
few additional steps of what we call the
virus life cycle so we have this viral
DNA that has some changes it's been that
have been introduced but I have again
portrayed the cell is fairly passive
here when in fact that's not the case
human cells over evolutionary time have
evolved lots of mechanisms to resist
this kind of change and in fact
resistance to change is very much a
feature of a human cell that has evolved
to maintain the status quo so these are
some of the thousands and thousands of
proteins that I mentioned are made by
the 20,000 human genes in a human cell
so one of these proteins tries to block
the change from viral RNA to viral DNA
so you'll remember this is about making
the message accessible but there is a
cellular protein that tries to keep this
from happening HIV has also evolved to
counter this cellular mechanism and in
fact what this virus does is it uses one
of its own proteins to tag the human
resistance protein and trick the cell
into thinking that that protein is trash
so the human cell has mechanisms for
getting rid of things that doesn't need
HIV tricks the cell into taking this
resistance protein chopping it up
into pieces and throwing it away a
couple of important fact features this
you'll remember that HIV has nine genes
that's not very many here we wrote that
one of those genes is devoted to
overcoming this resistance so that's a
major component of the genetic material
that this virus uses and keeps for
itself and that's one major lesson for
us as we think about trying to change an
existing system that has evolved to
maintain the status quo so introducing
an innovation into a system involves
encountering resistance somewhere in the
system and it may just be something as
simple as people saying we we don't do
things like that around here and in fact
in health innovations for example
breastfeeding in Brazil that's another
kind of Health innovation that's been
quite successful and yet there was a lot
of initial resistance women didn't
really do exclusive breastfeeding of
their babies so many changes have been
introduced for example advertising
campaigns or introducing changes to the
way that women were treated inside of
the hospital or something and like not
giving them formula right away those
kinds of mechanisms have been geared
toward overcoming resistance to this
change that's very productive for human
health and that's also a strong strong
lesson that we can take from this
biological model of spread so lots lots
lots going on here what's next well HIV
has overcome resistance so this is now
gone but I keep saying it really wants
to get into the DNA the cell it really
wants to take this DNA and make it part
of the cellular DNA that means this
becomes part of the norms the processes
the way that things are done inside of
the cell so the virus uses one of its
own proteins to bring its DNA inside of
the cellular this is a human nucleus and
actually insert its DNA into the human
double-stranded DNA inside of the cell
this process is called integration
once the viral DNA is integrated into
the human cellular DNA the cell is
infected forever that virus is there
forever and it's really not new anymore
this has now become part of what this
cell understands to be part of itself
and it makes proteins to make more virus
throughout the rest of its lifetime so
that's the next step we can take is to
integrate now in social science studies
of innovation in health systems that
terminology is actually similar we
talked about integrating we talked about
getting into the DNA of the system what
does that mean that really means that
something that was once knew is now part
of the norms of the system this is
something that we now we do do this
around here we do exclusive
breastfeeding we do have times for
another innovation I discussed in one of
the other videos is when patients come
to the door of the hospital with a
certain kind of heart attack if they get
treatment within 90 minutes they have
much better outcomes once that
innovation of changing treatment times
to 90 minutes or less became part of the
norms of the hospital then that is what
we do around here it's no longer new so
so far we've gone through these four
steps taking lessons from the way that
HIV makes itself a permanent part of a
cell to take to try to understand better
how we can implement health innovations
and human systems you'll notice that I
haven't really talked yet at all about
how HIV spreads to other systems in the
next video I'll go through in some
detail how HIV spreads and then
summarize what we think we can learn
from this biological model of going
viral and spreading something new in an
existing system